what do you so okay so
you got divorced and you said you were
married for 10 years and you got almost
10 years you got divorced and then you
entered the dating scene yeah what was
that like uh These Hoes crazy out here
no uh what was it like I I got an
education in the uh Generation X and
Millennials quite different
so uh younger Millennials tend to they
want to push off marriage as long as
they possibly could my generation was
not quite like that it was getting to
that point but but uh Millennials
typical like 29 30 32 34 but all the but
before all of that it was going to be in
these streets right they were going to
be out here streeting more times than a
Holland Tunnel all right so they were
going to be partying we call it the
Holland Tunnel in New York so they got
ran through more times on the Holland
Tunnel and the Holland Tunnel was the
busiest tunnel in New York it goes from
New York to New Jersey okay busiest
tunnel almost in America and a lot of
women started to
show that that's the lifestyle that they
lived Sex in the City yeah I'm gonna
live over here and go over here backpack
through Europe and blah blah blah and
then they were going to say oh I'm
irritable material now
well the the mayor's rates at Plum since
this generation that that generation
Millennials but they will say
Millennials are staying married more and
all of that stuff but they're not being
honest because they're still young many
of them are barely hitting 40.
so yeah that's now but you know there's
generation there's there's Baby Boomers
getting divorced right now in the 70s
right so just wait give it time but
dating wise I thought you know let me
give your your group your audience some
context when I got married and was
um engaged
there was no dating apps
there was no smartphones
there was not even text messages back
and forth they started making phones
were
um
by the time you guys see this I'm 47.
I'm 46 right now
so
there was no we had pagers and stuff
like that and little link pagers but we
have no smartphone where you could just
get an app swipe swipe swipe that was
2002. I think uh 2002 when I got engaged
2004 by the time I got married so that's
what that was and even dating they had
dating websites like match.com was
around I believe and um there was other
things but um you were a loser if you
were on a match
you were a complete loser like you were
a loser you on a dating site loser
so the idea that you couldn't get your
person out in the open
right that was losership so with that
being said I got divorced and and
separated 2012.
their smartphones now there's Tinder
there's plenty of fish there's now
Bumble uh there's Instagram it's just
starting up so that's what I got
reintroduced in the daily Marketplace so
it was like a highway it was like a fast
moving Highway when before it was a
crawl isn't did you when you did you try
to like Court some like hoes at all
foreign
I think uh what happened was sex was
much easier given
see this is what the crazy thing is to
get sex when I was about getting engaged
was tough you got to work you had to
talk to the woman and you you couldn't
you know unless you just met a fabulous
304 right and you were just lucky that
night remember it was getting lucky
there's no such thing as getting lucky
it was just almost guaranteed so by the
time I'm getting back out
um Instagram had just started becoming a
thing this was the baby infancy of the
Instagram and so I'm getting divorced or
during Instagram's Peak through people
were girls were flying in themselves in
they were flying themselves in girls
were driving hours I mean it was just
like what I called the digital sexual
Revolution
and it was nothing like that when I was
getting when I was uh married or
situation like that yeah it was nothing
like that so what what did you find out
about female nature like through this
um
whenever I found out about female nature
I just think that uh by that time I'll
find out how you doing on your yeah
that's good I keep checking that so
we're good we're good
female nature at that time
I think I was learning that what they
say and what they do or two separate
things
okay so that was basically the Epiphany
almost like they're saying this but
they're doing this they're doing this
under the cover of night but they're out
there um Angel you know what I mean like
that type of stuff and I'm like this is
crazy
so that probably was the epiphany
and um to not to not trust what they do
because I think what what people will
tell you and I will tell your young men
whatever your belief system in women is
going to be validated by social media
and dating apps so if you think girls
are out here being pure
well based on your experience is that
true
most of the time if you're using social
media and dating apps you're going to
find out that there's a lot of fast and
loose women
then that's going to validate what your
belief system is going forward and
backwards right you're going to look
back on the relationship then my girl
disappeared all the time Friday at eight
o'clock what was she doing you know she
was learning how to use her easy bake
oven or she was getting piped down right
now because it's easy
so you will know that because you'll be
the guy piping women down that Friday
and you know when she goes radio silent
on her guys that she's dating she got
multiple options and also when you get
that uh text message this is the text
message I don't know if it's popular now
but um the uh oh I fell asleep you know
you text him at eight o'clock oh I fell
asleep she text you in the morning I
fell asleep uh you know I'm getting back
to you well based on your experience you
know that that's not true she was
getting ran through it as we called it
over here she was getting her insides
pushed her esophagus that's what she was
doing she wasn't just falling asleep you
know so what about what about the guys
that say not all women are like that
I mean people will say there's no
unicorn there's no any of that type of
stuff uh if you believe that all not all
women are like that I tell you roll the
dice
roll a dice bet on her
and then you'll find out whether you're
gonna win or lose but I think we talk in
generalities here I can't talk
specifically about who does what but I
have some women that I would thought
never was three or fours and when they
got to the crib they was full on 304s
and then vice versa some women I was
like she is scab pill and skeezer and
then all of a sudden she get to the
house and she's all nervous about things
you know what the hell's going on
it's all different yeah yeah so
um
tell me about your interview can we talk
about the interview yeah we can talk
about that that seems to be going around
like wild right now yeah that's like
going crazy right now yeah
um yeah I got invited to this show and
then um you know Hafeez was there and
obviously people wanted to see the
debate between our particular content
but I didn't know he was going to be
there yeah so I showed up and I was like
what what we doing what yeah but so I
never considered it a debate I just
recorded the interview and said what I
said they were asking me questions
directly and then they would see if he
disagreed that's basically how the
debate went
so I was on trial
he would just basically get a chance to
respond that's that's kind of how I
looked at it as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible